foreign
if I were to ask you what is the
scariest type of Science Fiction you
probably wouldn't say evolutionary
horror mainly because it's a name I came
up with for this video but also because
it doesn't sound particularly
frightening Evolution isn't scary or is
it
twisting through the history of sci-fi
is a hidden sub-genre that drives Terror
from the altered self from The Uncanny
dread of a force beyond our control
evolving the human into the inhuman
so for this entry into the archive we'll
uncover the Terrors of this category and
dive into the type of sci-fi that I find
the most fear provoking of all
and I'm a scream
that was the voice of author Harlan
Ellison reading from his 1967 short
story of the same name it is one of the
most unpleasant works of fiction ever
written yet foundational to not just
sci-fi but the evolutionary horror
sub-genre in the narrative the last five
humans on Earth are held within a vast
underground Labyrinth being eternally
tormented by an artificial intelligence
called am originally a cold war
supercomputer am gained sentience but
found it was entombed within millions of
miles of circuits and wire that made up
its infrastructure forever unable to
move seeking Revenge It annihilated
planet Earth for unlike most evil Ai and
fiction am isn't rational but spiteful
filled with ceaseless hate for the
creatures who made it
am's true final revenge is altering the
five survivors one of them is turned
into a kind of early Simeon with Twisted
limbs incapable of rational thought all
are unable to die from old age an
adaptation that would have once been
considered a blessing but is now a
nightmarish curse and at the end of the
story the narrator is transmuted into an
amorphous blob unable to interact with
the world or Express their anguish hence
the title
I wouldn't necessarily say that I like
this story I don't think it's meant to
be liked or even understood the
notoriously irritable author rejected
pretty much all interpretations of his
writing throughout his life but if we
were to try and comprehend why this
story is so unsettling I can't think of
a better point of comparison than all
tomorrows
written and illustrated by Channel
Mainstay CM kozaman altomorrows Tales of
Humanity's encounter with the Q a
hostile alien species that like am
genetically Alters Humanity into a
myriad of unrecognizable forms for
seemingly no reason other than their own
Amusement the series has inspired
incredible fan works by artists like
tomage wozniakowski that translate the
images into tangible CGI animations
which help you more acutely feel the
suffering of these altered humanoids one
unfortunate group The lopsiders or
flattened out as if by a rolling pin and
made to crawl across the surface of a
high gravity planet for millions of
years the temp tours are turned into
beaked cones of Flesh rooted into the
soil like grotesque plants
perhaps the most tragic of all are the
mantelopes creatures with full human
minds and the bodies of grazing animals
left to fend for themselves upon the
queue's sudden disappearance these
beings live agonizing lives able to see
and understand the world around them but
helpless to change it the book describes
mournful herds roaming across the plains
for centuries singing songs of
desperation and loss
[Music]
perhaps mercifully The Selective forces
of evolution make their Agony a short
one as more instinctual animalistic
mantelope proved to be better grazers in
a grim reminder that the human mind
isn't sacred to The evolutionary process
the herds soon fall into contented
silence forgetting all they once were
beyond the horror there's a quiet
unplaceable sadness at play here
all tomorrows and I have no mouth or
uncomfortable reminders of Humanity's
fragility extracting Terror from the
fact that Evolution made us and could
erase us just as easily few things are
more intrinsically disturbing than
something be it am or the queue changing
us so completely we forget how to be
human
but what about a story where this
alteration is self-inflicted Altered
States is an often overlooked movie
about a scientist who uses a sensory
deprivation tank in combination with
psychoactive substances to accelerate
and regress evolutionarily renowned
critic Roger Ebert described it as a
film that hurls its characters headlong
through billions of years of evolution
and finds nothing except an anguish
scream I think I get what he means over
the course of the film the lead
scientist melts into a primordial soup
reverts into a caveman-like creature and
goes on a midnight Rampage and even
becomes an amorphous mass of
Consciousness that transcends reality
it's a whole lot not all the visuals
have aged flawlessly it's a movie like
the culture of psychedelics that
inspired it that's of a specific time
but there's a through line of human
Folly of experimenting with forces
beyond your control that still resonates
to day
Altered States can be better understood
in conversation with an equally Bonkers
Time Capsule the sixth finger an episode
of The Twilight Zone style show The
Outer Limits it tells the story of a man
who turns into a Weird large-headed elf
guy with six fingers by using a machine
that accelerates Evolution it's not the
most uh scientifically rigorous work the
evolution process is literally
controlled by a lever that switches
between forward and backward nor is it
particularly frightening by today's
standards but at the time the concept of
evolutionary horror was new and it
scared people the episode was banned or
at least it almost was before Network
Executives stepped in and cut the ending
where the lead devolves helplessly from
a primate into primordial goop the
humanity erased ensure part of why this
was cut was due to fear of
anti-evolution backlash this was the
early 60s but either way this idea
unsettled people for all their silliness
Altered States in the sixth finger or
intriguing warnings about tampering with
the laws of nature in changing the
source of the mutations from a hostile
external Force into something
self-inflicted they become Parables of
human ignorance depicting Evolution as
an Unstoppable power that will change
you utterly if you mess with it for what
could be scarier than a destructive
force beyond your control that you bring
upon yourself
I mean getting chased by a monster
probably
on a surface level the Xenomorphs of the
alien franchise seem like the complete
opposite of horror derived from the
altered self through the ultimate
external threat the other with a capital
O something fundamentally inhuman and
dissimilar from the protagonists they
hunt especially with their Decades of
extra baggage from sequels today
Xenomorphs feel more like non-specific
monsters than a reflection of ourselves
yet the design of the alien didn't start
as an alien it comes from a portrait of
a biomechanical humanoid by Swiss artist
H.R Giger altered humans are Central to
geeker's Art often appearing in tableaus
where body parts seem to melt and merge
with the mechanical yet even at their
most extreme gigger subject somehow
always register as humanoid it's this
faint recognition that makes the
Xenomorphs of aliens so frightening this
tug at the back of your mind that the
thing chasing you is somehow familiar
as parasites that reproduce by growing
inside their hosts the Xenomorphs are in
some ways altered humans it's been
established over the course of the
franchise that the aliens take DNA from
the life forms they develop within able
to steal the very things that make us
human like our bipedal stature in order
to more effectively hunt us but
ultimately the Xenomorphs are of course
not actual people
the same cannot be said for the monsters
in Dead Space recently remastered Dead
Space is a horror game that traps you
within the ishimura a massive ship that
is essentially a giant tomb haunted by
the vengeful dead Necromorphs are
hostile life forms clearly inspired by
the Xenomorphs all the way down to their
name but the difference is that each
Necromorph was once a Living member of
the crew now mutated into unfeeling
monsters it's a small change that
profoundly Alters the flavor of Terror
you experience because now every enemy
you slay comes with the palpable
knowledge that you're fighting something
that was once just like you while
playing you find yourself wondering if
each necromorph's human mind is still in
there watching their bodies do
nightmarish things while being helpless
to stop them and if you fail you know
that you will suffer the same fate
doomed to live eternally as an inhuman
shell
there's enough isolated space station
horror that it could be considered its
own genre but I think part of why many
aren't as effective is because they make
the inevitable hostile life form too
unfamiliar a huge part of what makes
aliener Dead Space frightening isn't
just that the characters are being
hunted by a monster but that they're
being hunted by a distorted echo of
themselves
and I don't think there's any movie that
captures this nightmare better than John
Carpenter's The Thing while set in
Antarctica instead of space the thing no
doubt belongs to the same isolation
genre in the film a group of researchers
are stalked by an organism that digests
and replicates its victims the life form
in the thing is constantly
shape-shifting its Myriad of forms
brought to life with visceral practical
effects but what's even scarier than the
dripping bodily Terrors is how the film
captures the agonizing paranoia of being
hunted by A Perfect imitator that can
look and sound almost exactly like you
but isn't you
[Applause]
the most unsettling forms the thing
takes are not when it appears like a
horrific monstrosity but when it's
indistinguishable from other humans the
film practically Smothers you with its
atmosphere of doubt in isolation to the
point where you feel like you're trapped
alongside the characters
in an earlier black and white film based
on the same novel the alien is just a
guy in a monster suit aside from being
less scary this threat is surmountable
able to be overpowered by military men
with nerves of Steel a sentiment
reflective of the 1950s it's not our
evolutionary Superior or Flawless
imitation because surely no alien could
rival us in our Mighty intellect right
in an earlier version of the alien
script the film would have concluded
with the xenomorph perfectly mimicking a
crew member's voice to send out a
distress signal and then wait to be
rescued by another ill-fated crew and so
what was once barely humanoid ends up a
near Flawless impressionist
stories like alien dead space and the
thing take the fear of the altered self
and make it external pitting humans
against their own warped reflection and
the outcome of these films challenges
are Notions of human superiority the
very idea that would be difficult to
imitate or outwit it's no accident that
most of these movies end with few or no
survivors they remind us that in the
game of evolution humans can be out
competed just as easily as any other
species
yet notably not all works of
evolutionary horror are nihilistic and
perhaps no film walks the line between
Dreams and Nightmares quite as closely
as Alex Garland's Annihilation Loosely
based on a novel of the same name
Annihilation is ultimately a movie about
change the story follows four scientists
on their expedition into the Shimmer a
hallucinatory region where everything
refracts and mutates into new forms
which means that unlike most stories in
this genre it's not just humans who are
mutated within the haze of the Shimmer
plants meld together with their
neighbors animals take on the properties
of other species and even light waves
seem to blend into glassy new forms
while some of these alterations are
dangerous others seem benign
Annihilation isn't just disturbing it's
also beautiful
most stories in the altered self genre
Focus purely on repulsive mutations
scorn is a game that absolutely fits
into this category in that world altered
humanoids ooze out of every crack and
crevice their bodies Twisted to be used
as batteries or computers or a source of
raw material it's a realm utterly
stripped of humanity where ugliness is
pretty much the only thing that remains
inside note despite the Avalanche of
unsettling imagery that they're
subjected to the playable character
quite literally has no mouth with which
to scream
but Annihilation stuns just as often as
it distresses making it a story is much
about creation as it is destruction at
times the Shimmer seems like a cancer a
disease eating away at the land meant to
mirror the self-destructive Tendencies
of the main characters at other points
it feels like nature reclaiming itself
reveling in the inherent disorder of
evolution it's unclear if the Shimmer
has any malicious intent whatsoever it
may Simply Be Evolution personified an
impartial engine of creation
it was destroying everything
it wasn't destroying
it was changing everything
he was making something new
not all the visuals of annihilation are
necessarily meant to be taken literally
it is the film like the Shimmer itself
that is endlessly interpretable but the
film leaves you with the possibility
that change even radical self-altering
change isn't inherently negative
indeed not all works of evolutionary
horror are quite as nihilistic as they
appear at first the famously Grim
ultimaros also has a surprising amount
of optimism as many of the mutated
humanoids re-evolve their intelligence
and form new societies seemingly
suggesting that even in an inhuman form
the human Spirit can remain even I have
no mouth and I must scream has a faint
glimmer of hope at the end of the short
story the narrator finds a way to put
the other four humans out of their
misery although the narrator knows this
is an act that will Doom them to Eternal
Solitude and torment they perform it
anyway proving that there was still a
spark of human compassion that am wasn't
able to Snuff out
like any genre not all evolutionary
horror takes the same approach or
reaches the same thematic conclusions
nor is everything that falls within the
category inherently effective and
terrifying in fact some of it is pretty
goofy there's a sci-fi film from 2001
about a meteorite that speeds up natural
selection simply titled Evolution that
takes a lot of the themes mentioned here
and plays them for Laughs while the film
wasn't received particularly well it is
interesting to see these tropes taken in
such a radically different direction
furthermore what works of sci-fi
actually belong to evolutionary horror
can be tricky to define the aliens in a
quiet place looked spooky and we can
assume that they evolved but evolution
itself isn't really present or
thematically relevant to the narrative
in a meaningful way most stories
featuring zombies Lurch along the line
of the sub-genre to varying degrees with
the majority involving some disease that
alters the humans it contaminates in
many zombie movies The Terror comes more
from the scale of the hordes in the
conventional thrill of being chased by
something dangerous than from physical
changes to the infected some exceptions
like The Last of Us exist as in that
franchise more fear is extracted from
the fundamental ways the fungal
infection Alters its hosts additionally
more emphasis is placed on how the
cordyceps function biologically and how
they evolved earning it a clearer spot
in the genre although since this is a
category I came up with while developing
this video I'd say it's still debatable
what stories belong in its ranks and I'm
sure there are a few that I've
overlooked
in the end perhaps it's no surprise that
evolutionary horror is such a scary
hidden genre of sci-fi if thought about
in abstract terms evolution is almost an
Eldritch concept a law of the universe
that changes all organic beings from
humans to the tiniest cell whether those
changes are non-threatening or
nightmarish depends on the story and
your point of view but one thing that
stays consistent across the sub-genre is
that fighting evolution is futile and
playing with it is dangerous from the
Slime we came into the Slime we will
return
as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video